I just wanna win why can't I fly for
senator there's much wear in the razor
burn Segway ball jump here to start okay
so what do I do about this let's try
this again without sucking I didn't know
that I had to bonk it with my head I
thought was just gonna kill me yes bash
it with your head I missed it do it
again
how does it even happen how do I go oh
my god go wait no it's oh oh I got a
first up to go that's so cool look at me
why I lay off the door holes wherever
yay good boy
swore what the hell oh my god this is a
kill the ball wall I'm so sorry I can't
control Kirby instances
when it's actually in the real world
that's pretty horrific I imagine this is
what he actually jump test wait I can
make it oh no again okay neon
slow-motion what right in the neck was
that the winning objective awesome spike
fall this isn't a spike fall oh it is
how do I lose this I lose I think I lost
[Music]
how we just gotta wiggle it off there we
go
now I'm in no trouble going my way
[Music]
minecraft pony ride oh so adorable why
is that so adorable doing anything what
is it with these games they're so here
we live doom I don't think I can't
escape maybe my son could it get out of
here son leave me
Oh son don't leave me watch this watch
these sick moves okay never lose I think
I won Oh walking mecha who's it for
oh it's still just as elegant as the
last one come here put up your dukes
anybody want to fight me somebody put up
their Zeus
I'm in the building I've arrived where's
my welcoming party I just want to hold
your hand oh there you are
hey how you doing good okay well
whenever you're ready I got your men
over here from this club there we go
[Music]
yeah Oh Oh what's happening to me my
crotch
feels weird headfirst into tent nice
planking but I think you're doing it
wrong oh nice backflip exactly what you
want to do when you need stability Oh
give me a chance give that man a chance
ah dad's back from the dead
a man's back tweakers horrible vengeance
tasty sweet breath of life yeah this is
the one I can feel it yeah yeah yeah
yeah point zero zero zero zero one
percent possible is what it said oh I
think I get I'm supposed to launch
myself Wow
I'm supposed to launch myself from
triangle two trying
oh this is creative oh it's so creative
oh it's such a challenge there's no boy
ow
I quit ow ow okay baby they weren't
lying with her oh when they said that
this was gonna be impossible because I'm
having a tough time playing this game
Oh God yes yes crap
no don't care oh now you see he's taking
the are and now you see he's taking his
dad gone now you see he's taking his
elegant sweet God he's taking his
sweet-ass time they get over maybe the
first time isn't good enough
[Music]
hang on cookies let me use my fairy just
do that over again you don't feel bad
cuz I've got a healthy supply of dye for
you
listen I know that my ass is expertly
crafted but you don't need to stare and
gasp in amazement you can just touch it
or you don't have hands well I don't
have legs so don't matter we can get
along I don't know the answer is not far
yeah okay yeah yes
you think that someone could have come
up oh I'm a walk I'm a walk a gay happy
4th of July
let me just cut down this Christmas tree
so we can celebrate it properly
I've tried to make it a pardon me lady
why are you so pretty this come with me
I need a date for this whatever this is
a we declare that America is the best
cut throats while sorry about your foot
there should be got some in your eye
pardon me I got in your hair a little
bit mmm very interesting over here lady
concert brother
okay I pledge allegiance to the okay bye
hear me Barbie make way try to get
through this okay bye
I fall
hey guys thank you for 50 episodes in
almost two years of happy wheels
highlights I uploaded the first video
November 13th of 2012 and I originally
said that I might be winding down the
series but after 50 episodes and just
seeing the love from you guys in the
outpouring of how much you enjoy these
videos I'm not gonna stop so long as you
want me to keep making them so expect
them fairly regularly you know if not
every week than every other week or so
whenever I get a chance to play it
because the community behind happy
wheels has been so creative and happy
wheels to actually might be coming out
very soon so either way just thank you
guys for sticking with me and this
series for so long thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video